i like the analogy or the kind of the
awareness that hey we have this
giant bowl of ice cream that's melting
that's that's your cash pile that's
melting and the heat is basically
the money printer that is uh causing
acid inflation
ice cube that's melting and i save a 500
million dollar ice cube
and it's melting 20 percent a year
and it will be gone and finally so you
needed to do something with that you
didn't want it to all melt away
so you decided to do this now a couple
quick questions
one is uh this is sort of rapid fire
i've had a couple rapid fire questions
for you
in 20 years from now what do you think
has generated more
value uh or more income to the company
to microstrategy is it the operating
income of microstrategy or the
investment income of the bitcoin it
holds
the investment income for sure okay and
then uh
you know to be to be very clear what
happened in march of 2020
is when the cost of capital goes to 25
that means that every investor and all
investment income
every every investor generated 25 more
doing nothing
right and every main street company that
worked 25
harder got nothing right right you
literally
tilt the playing field so that if you
don't
own if you own an assets you're
having the best year of the 30 years and
if you don't own assets it's impossible
to have a good year
right and um and so
so the second question is um you
uh as you acquire as you acquire more
and more bitcoin is
microstrategy bet like do you just
position the company at this point like
it's a bitcoin etf
it's like buy this buy this bitcoin
buying it
it's not a bitcoin etf everybody's
you're sloppy with those words
an etf is a company that invests in
securities
and it tries to keep its assets under
management equal to the amount of shares
of etf that it sold it's a financial
company
an etp is a similar type of company that
invests in commodities
if you create you know if you create
this bitcoin entity
that that equalizes assets under
management equal to the shares you sell
you created a bitcoin etp
we're neither of those things we're not
a finance company we're not an etf we're
not an etp we're not eq
we're not buying or selling bitcoin to
equalize assets under management
we're an operating company that owns
property bitcoin is property
and in that way you should think of it
as a company that like i
i bought a million acres of land in
texas or i bought uh
a million gallons of of fill in the
blank
a million bushels of soybean you can buy
any kind of property
right and and you're holding it on your
balance sheet
as a company right that's what we that's
what we are
now what's your question you are talking
about like let's say the
the cost of capital uh being 25 right
because
since march that's what the s p 500 has
done but the the stock market goes
you know it does go up and down in years
where
you know the market dips and and goes up
you know the average or you know over
time the geometric mean is whatever
seven or eight percent something like
that so
d some would argue okay yes this year
assets inflated by that much that
doesn't mean next year it's going to
remain at 25
a year um and so you have to make some
prediction right and so
are you are you basically forecasting it
at 25
15 10 8 and does the decision change
at a certain number there so
so gen first of all for the decade from
2010 to
thousand and twenty it was generally
about eight percent
like it was it was pretty consistent and
the single biggest driver
of cost to capital is the rate at which
the
broad money supply expands
and if you look at if you go google m2
money supply fed
you'll get a chart and you'll see the ch
by the way the chart's not all over the
place the chart is very consistent
seven percent slope for a decade it's
not jerking around
so it's not that volatile it was very
consistent monetary policy for a decade
then that chart goes like this straight
up 24
so if you uh if if you're going to make
a decision as an investor
and this is any investor what it this
this has to do this applies to all 400
trillion dollars worth of
investors and it applies to every
company on earth they all have the same
exact thing they have to calculate which
is
you have to estimate the rate at which
the money supply will expand
each year for the next eight years and
so that's the same
if you want to figure out the signal or
or the single most important thing in
the world for everyone
but for everyone 7.8 billion people for
100 million companies for
everyone with money on earth and
everyone that earns a salary on earth
this is the big idea of the podcast you
have to estimate
the rate at which the currency is going
to expand
and if you believe the currency is going
to continue to expand
at 15 a year for the next eight years
you come to one conclusion
if you plug in 10 it's a different
conclusion
if it's 25 it's a different conclusion
so what do i think um i think
that um 15
is 15 for the next eight years is
reasonable
um if you're a pessimist you could say
if you're an optimist you could say 10.
but
um the money supply is expanding because
the federal reserve and the eu central
bank are buying a trillion dollars
worth of um bonds every year each
and it's also expanding because uh the
the government of the eu
and the us are running a multi-trillion
dollar deficit
and it is also expanding because of
trillion dollar plus stimulus
and there's no reason to think that's
going to change in the next four years
and i don't think in the next eight
years i think i think that at the point
that the democrats took control of the
senate
and the house you saw that you have um
if you could have you could have
forecasted 12 percent
inflation if it was a it was a split
government
but i think that in a a non-split
government there seems to be remarkable
consensus that we should run deficits
continue to keep interest rates low and
continue to stimulate the economy
so what does that mean if you plug in a
number
15 it means that the risk-free interest
rate or the
the risk-free return is 15 it means you
have to generate in excess of 15
on your money every year for the next
four years in order to stay ahead of
the rate of asset inflation a reasonable
person would say
the assets are going to inflate at that
rate that's
that's pretty much what they do that
means that
if your company is not growing its cash
flows
you know at a 20 rate then it's not
going to hold value as a stock it means
that if your bond is paying you
an interest rate of less than 15 percent
you're destroying value in the bond if
your rent yield is less than 15 percent
your commercial real estate's destroying
value and
if you're holding cash you're losing 15
percent of it a year
that's that's the negative real yield so
once you actually uh embrace the idea of
asset inflation and asset inflation
equals cost of capital equals the rate
of the money supply expansion
once you have that rate then you realize
that there's a negative real
real yield on everything except for
bitcoin for the most part the negative
real yield on gold is three percent
that's the rate at which we mine it
or hypothecate it the negative real
yield on sovereign debt is about 12
13 the negative real yield on corporate
debt is ten percent
every company that's got a growth rate
of less than fifteen percent has got a
negative real yield on it so
you know once you do that then you can
then what you realize is
you can't really have a business
strategy as a company
unless you find a way to solve the
treasury problem
so the big idea here is
you want to fix any company sweep all
the cash flows
into bitcoin convert the treasury into
bitcoin
borrow against your future cash flows
and dollars convert that into bitcoin
finance all your fixed assets in dollars
convert that into bitcoin
and issue equity as much as you can now
at the highest valuation you can now in
dollars and invest in bitcoin
right and and you might say why bitcoin
well because bitcoin is the apex
property it's the most scarce
monetary asset in the universe you can't
make any more of it
it's encrypted money and and what that
means is
it's least likely to be impaired by
a property tax an execution issue
um money printing
delusion counterparty risk
and corruption so we have we have
engineered
a superior asset a thermodynamically
sound
technically superior asset it's placed
on a global
digital monetary network which is open
an open protocol and the combination
of the the the apex
asset on the open monetary system
makes it the um the most disruptive
technology in the world
when you were first starting
microstrategy you were you were in the
weeds you were thinking
i have to make a product that solves a
problem
and i have to make money off of it right
now
you've gone way up the hierarchy of now
we can do whatever we want
now you can do whatever you want at what
point did you notice a shift like oh my
gosh like this business is stable
it's working it's working pretty well uh
yep it's quite predictable at what point
did that shift happen because what
you're talking about now
is quite important to what i think we
look we solved our problem when we
actually embraced bitcoin
i i i could say to you oh yeah well
when i had 500 million in cash in the
bank i could and we were focused
but the problem with that is that if you
have a bunch of cash generating zero
interest the cost of capital goes to 25
then all the public company investors
forsake the company
and if the stock if if the stock market
forsakes the company the mainstream
media for stakes the company
right then the employees become dejected
because
eventually you're going to have facebook
amazon apple or google steal
every one of your employees if you can't
drive the stock up right
nobody wants to invest in a company that
makes a lot of money growing at five
percent a year
i mean it's it seems brutal to say that
but it wouldn't be true if the cost
capital was zero
if we had a sound money policy in this
country
then you could hold your head up high
and say i run this great restaurant
and we made a lot of money last year
we're going to make a lot of money this
year and our plan is to keep doing what
we've been doing
and everybody pat you on the back and
say that's good that's honorable
but if if i tell you i'm going to
devalue the the cash by 25
a year or 20 a year at some point
you're driven into this cycle where
i have to either do a big acquisition to
keep my revenues growing
i have to take extreme risk and do
dilutive acquisitions
or i have to go borrow billions of
dollars to buy the stock back to
leverage up the cash flow per share
and if i don't do either those things
the investors dump the stock and they
dump the stock the employees start
feeling like
you know why don't they go work
someplace cool and hot and
you're gonna get all your engineers
stripped away by facebook or
or amazon or something so the truth is
when we actually fix the balance sheet
we fix the stock and we fix that you
know at this point
the company has five billion dollars
more than five billion dollars in assets
if the if the cost of capital remains at
let's say it goes up 20 percent if if we
print 20 percent more money next year
i can reasonably expect to generate a
billion dollars in investment income
which would be a you know 20 increase in
bitcoin right
but the truth is i can reasonably expect
better than that
if the cost of capital is 10 i can
reasonably expect 500 million investment
income
well all two thousand people doing a
hundred thousand things right perfectly
for the entire year competing against
microsoft that has
more money than god they can generate 75
million a year
okay so so the truth is the company
its future became secure when we
actually converted the balance sheet
to bitcoin because now
we don't have to struggle let me say it
a different way
i don't think any company could be
successful without a financial strategy
in the year 2021
like i wouldn't have said it three four
years ago
if you have a sound money macroeconomic
environment where the money supply is
expanding at two or three percent a year
you can go out and make things and
create things and market things and sell
things and service things
and generate cash with that and then and
that makes sense but if the money supply
is expanding at 20 percent a year
you need to own assets because
because what's happening is
no one's going to invest in any project
that doesn't generate more than the 20
hurdle rate and so what who can generate
consistently
risk-free 20 returns you have to be a
monopoly
you have to have a digital monopoly or
some kind of monopoly so
it becomes exponentially harder to grow
and what
and so what happens next all these other
companies could get squeezed out of the
ecosystem
right there they get decapitalized and
rendered insolvent
by by the monetary policy
so i i would say that you know
if i can get my st my stock was
twenty 120 a share what is it right now
like uh
i haven't checked in the market 768.
okay so
if i if i get my stock up then
i can actually make my shareholders
happy i can change the narrative
i can recruit i can retain talent
i can get that you know i can inspire
the confidence of my customers
i can i can drive momentum
and then we can do what we want to do i
guess it's it's similar to
if you're a university and you had no
endowment
you know and or university there's a
billion dollar endowment or
university is a 100 billion dollar
endowment you know
if you're a professor which university
you want to work for if you're a student
where you want to go
you know do you have a shiny building
coming or not right
at the end of the day right money is a
measure of energy
and so if you have monetary assets you
have energy and if you have high energy
you can pursue
your vision you know with integrity
and what percentage of your time now are
you spending
on this on investing the income
versus on the day-to-day of micro
strategy of just the
the business as usual making the
products that making business
intelligence products versus investing
the the income
um i'm i'm the ceo but we have a
president
and the president of the company is fong
lee and he actually has
day-to-day operational responsibility
for sales marketing and even technology
development at this point
so i'm the chairman and the ceo i i
oversee the company strategy
and i oversee that i oversee
financial strategies i oversee long-term
direction and i and
i oversee technology strategy but i'm
not
i'm not in the weeds in the day-to-day
running the business
that's really left for the operating
executive team
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on a
road less travel never looking back